Yo ! Avant toute chose je voulais vous remercier pour la vidéo précédente
qui vous a énormément plu.
En plus c'était une vidéo très personnelle donc voilà je suis encore plus heureux.
Aujourd'hui on va parler d'autre chose puisque pour beaucoup d'entre nous, confinement rime avec solitude.
Alors il y en a un qui termine en "ement" et l'autre en "itude"
donc c'est pas vraiment une vraie rime mais c'est plus dans le sens que ...
... ils vont ensemble souvent.
C'était plus ça que je voulais dire.
C'est assez spécial la solitude parce que personne d'autre que nous peut nous dire si on se sent seul.
Alors que par exemple il y a plein d'autres émotions ou sentiments
qui se voient qui se sentent etc
mais la solitude vous pouvez être au milieu de plein de gens qui vous aiment
et vous sentir quand même seul.
En fait c'est un sentiment qui est très intime et moi d'une certaine manière ce confinement il m'a fait penser à l'histoire
de Henry David Thoreau : un philosophe américain du 19ème siècle.
En mars 1845 Thoreau commence à construire une petite cabane de pain de 13 mètres carrés
sur les rives de l'étang de Waldem dans le Massachusetts et le 4 juillet le jour de l'indépendance il s'y installe.
C'est une cabane qui est éloignée des hommes mais en même temps pas trop non plus puisque la première maison
est à environ 1-2 km kilomètres.
Alors la question c'est : "pourquoi il s'isole ?"
Mais ça, on ne sait pas trop il y a plein de raisons c'est pas très clair.
C'est pour écrire son bouquin c'est aussi parce qu'il a malencontreusement par accident brûler une partie de la forêt
donc il est pas forcément très apprécié dans le coin et parce que c'est pas un très grand fan du genre humain.
Dans cette maisonnette de 13 mètres carrés il va rester deux ans, deux mois et 2 jours et il va écrire : "Walden" qui va profondément
marquer la littérature américaine et qui va même créer un genre puisque c'est le "Nature writing"
Walden c'est un endroit où Thoreau a pu se recentrer sur ce qui lui semblait essentiel.
Alors des fois je prononce "toro" des fois je prononce "thoro" je ne sais pas comment ça se prononce
*téléphone qui prononce : "Henry David Thoreau"*
Du coup on reprend pour la dernière fois.
Walden c'est un endroit où Thoreau a pu se recentrer sur ce qui lui semblé essentielle.
Un endroit où il pouvait se concentrer,
s'éloigner de tout le bruit des humains il pouvait du coup faire ce qui était beaucoup plus dur à faire habituellement dont écrire son livre
qui serait aussi un hommage à son frère mort à 27 ans du tétanos car il s'est coupé en se rasant.
Ouais on pouvait mourir de ça et puis on a inventé les vaccins.
Heureusement que ça existe quoi !
Que tout le monde se rende compte
de la chance qu'on a quoi de les avoir. D'ailleurs c'est marrant là il en manque juste un et on voit comme c'est la merde.
C'est fou hein? j'ai pas pu m'en empêcher !
Il profita aussi de cette retraite pour lire énormément et apprendre dans une lettre à un ami il écrit :"le yogi absorbé par la contemplation
contribue à sa façon à la création il respire un parfum divin il entend des choses magnifiques
d'une certaine façon à de rares éclaircies mêmes moi je suis yogi".
Et c'est quelque chose qu'on a pu observer aussi pendant ce confinement on a vu l'essor de la méditation du yoga etc
et c'est des activités qui souvent riment avec solitude c'est pour ça que les retraites
méditatives par exemple sont généralement des retraites silencieuses où l'on est seul.
Je vous lis une autre citation de Thoreau
que j'aime bien :
"Je suis partie vivre dans les bois parce que je voulais vivre en toute intentionnalité
me confronter aux données essentielles de la vie et voir si je pouvais apprendre ce qu'elle avait à m'enseigner
plutôt que de constater au moment de mourir que je n'avais point vécu"
Et c'est intéressant parce que dans notre esprit il y a quelque chose de glorieux, de courageux à cette solitude-là
alors que la solitude d'un enfant à qui personne ne parle dans la cour de récré
bah elle fait un petit peu de la peine c'est la différence entre la solitude qui est subie et la solitude qui est choisie.
En anglais ils ont "Loneliness" qui est teintée de tristesse
et "solitude" qui respire la réflexion et je pense que ce deuxième mot nous manque
parce que ces deux états qui n'ont rien à voir et du coup vu qu'on n'a que le mot "solitude"
et bien il a un petit peu une mauvaise connotation or la solitude on en a besoin elle est nécessaire.
Elle est nécessaire à la réflexion, elle nous donne l'occasion de
contempler nos actions et de développer notre conscience
et je suis pas le seul qui le dit. Il y a une philosophe dont de mémoire je n'ai jamais parlé sur cette chaîne est
vraiment je pensais pas le faire sur un sujet comme la solitude c'est : "Hannah Arendt" alors c'est une émigrée
juive allemande qui a fui le nazisme et qui a trouvé refuge aux États-Unis
elle-même ne se considère pas vraiment comme philosophe mais plutôt politologue
et elle a travaillé toute sa vie sur le lien entre l'individu et la cité avec notamment un focus sur le totalitarisme
mais au cours de son travail elle s'est aussi penchée sur la solitude et elle a écrit ceci :
"être avec soi-même et juger par soi-même s'articule et s'actualise dans le processus de pensée
et chaque processus de pensée est une activité au cours de laquelle je me parle de ce qui se trouve me concerner.
Le mode d'existence qui est présent dans ce dialogue silencieux je l'appellerai maintenant solitude.
La solitude représente donc davantage que les autres modes d'être seul en particulier surtout l'isolement
et elle est différente de. La solitude implique que bien que seul je sois avec quelqu'un c'est-à-dire moi-même
elle signifie que je suis 2 en 1"
comme le shampoing.
Cette réflexion sur la solitude et ce qu'elle implique
elle est d'autant plus importante dans notre monde qui est hyperconnecté et où on n'est jamais vraiment seul.
Moi je me souviens j'ai dû traverser la moitié de la terre,
m'enfermer dans un temple avec des moines qui ont pris tout ce que j'avais
pour pouvoir ressentir ce que cherchait. Bon c'était peut-être un peu extrême, j'étais peut-être pas obligé de faire tout ça
mais en tout cas c'est très dur quoi c'est assez dur dans notre monde je trouve de ressentir ce truc-là. C'est important de rappeler que
ce n'est pas parce que la solitude bonne est nécessaire à la réflexion qu'elle implique la solitude mauvaise.
C'est pas parce qu'on réfléchit qu'on s'isole. Souvenez-vous la caverne de Platon,
le philosophe c'est celui qui sort de la caverne seul et qui accède au monde des idées
mais il ne fais pas que contempler le monde des idées tout seul, il en fait profiter la cité.
Parce que oui toucher à cette solitude et en jouir c'est quelque chose qu'on ne va pas faire seulement pour nous
mais aussi pour les autres
avant d'être avec les autres.
Il faut pouvoir être avec soi-même et c'est quelque chose qui est vrai à tous les niveaux :
c'est vrai pour l'amitié, c'est vrai pour le couple et c'est vrai pour la société.
Il y a plein d'autres niveaux mais ceux-là sont ceux qui sont le plus marquants pour cet exemple je trouve.
Après Walden Thoreau a apporté énormément à la société il a été notamment reconnu pour un concept qu'il a créé dans un essai.
En juillet 1846 il se fait mettre en prison parce qu'il n'a pas payé ses impôts
pour protester contre l'esclavagisme du sud et la guerre américano-mexicaine.
Sauf qu'il passe qu'une seule nuit en prison parce que sa tante lui paye sa caution ce qui le rend ouf.
Et en rentrant, dans sa petite cabane qu'est-ce qui fait ?
Il fait le premier brouillon, le premier jet en fait de ce qui va donner l'un de ces essais les plus connus : "la désobéissance civile"
Et donc c'est lui qui a créé le concept de désobéissance civile en gros. Hannah Arendt aussi a soulignée l'importance de la solitude
non pas pour soi mais pour la société : en 1961 elle est commissionnée par : "le New Yorker" pour
couvrir le procès d'Adolf Eichmann, un officier SS qui a pris part à l'orchestration de l'Holocauste est en fait elle se demander
comment c'était possible de faire quelque chose d'aussi monstrueux et elle se disait ya que des psychopathes cinglés pour prendre part à la Shoah.
C'est pas possible et en fait elle a été surprise de voir que même si ses actions étaient monstrueuses
Eichmann la personne, l'individu
était au final assez ordinaire.
qui n'était pas démoniaque.
Elle a attribué son immoralité et sa capacité à faire de tels crimes à ça : "Thoughtlessness" (son absence de pensée)
pour elle c'était l'incapacité Eichmann à s'arrêter et à réfléchir qui avait fait de lui un monstre.
Pour elle si on perd notre capacité à être seul avec nous-mêmes alors on perd notre capacité à réfléchir
et on peut facilement se faire emporter
notamment par la foule et c'est intéressant parce que Sénèque dans : "la vie heureuse"
nous dit que le chemin de la foule n'est pas le bon il dit ça exactement :
"il est nuisible en effet d'être attaché à ceux qui nous précèdent
chacun préférant croire plutôt que juger on ne porte jamais de jugement sur la vie on est toujours dans la croyance
et l'erreur transmise de main en main nous remue en tous sens et nous mène à notre ruine nous périssons par l'exemple des autres
nous guérirons pour peu que nous nous séparions de la foule".
C'est donc aussi ça la solitude c'est pas que pour se développer soi c'est aussi pour développer la société
mais il y a un contraste que je trouve super-intéressant
Thoreau bah ce n'était pas un pacifiste. Il a soutenu par exemple le raid armé de l'abolitionniste John Brown
et quand John Brown a été pendu,
Thoreau a fait un discours hyper fort sous un drapeau américain renverser
ce qui est un gros signe de contestation.
Et pourtant, et pourtant
à Walden,
vous ne trouverez rien d'autre que de la sérénité,
du calme.
C'est un endroit paisible
et l'essence de tout ce que je viens de vous dire
réside dans ce contraste
Thoreau  disait aussi : "je ne me suis jamais senti seul ou du moins oppressé par un sentiment de solitude
sauf une fois :
c'était quelques semaines après mon arrivée dans la forêt quand pendant une heure je me suis demandé si le voisinage proche des hommes
n'était pas essentiel à une vie sereine et en bonne santé"
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu !
J'espère que ça vous a intéressé moi je voulais vous parler de Thoreau et en fait en creusant le sujet
ça paraissait évident de parler de Hannah Arendt aussi et voilà ça fait une vidéo un petit peu plus étoffé que ce que j'avais prévu
mais c'est pas plus mal
mais voilà je voulais juste vous parlez de Thoreau, de la solitude et à quel point la solitude est importante, à quel point
on a une mauvaise image de cette solitude-là et je pense pour les mauvaises raisons et voilà je pense
qu'il faut changer notre lien
à cette solitude-là
et la cultiver davantage voilà je trouvais que cette vidéo elle était importante à sortir avant la vidéo que je vais faire sur
notre addiction au téléphone parce que voilà l'addiction au téléphone aussi nous empêche d'accéder à cette solitude.
C'est une vidéo qui est très importante pour moi.
Donc voilà sa sera la prochaine vidéo de cette chaîne normalement donc si ce n'est pas le cas :
abonnez-vous!
je suis en débrief de cette vidéo-là tout de suite sur twitch.tv/cyrusnorth
l'ancien débrief que j'avais fait sur ma précédente vidéo
c'était ouf genre la soirée s'était dingue, on a dépassé les 10 000 follower par exemple sur Twitch
donc ça me fait énormément plaisir je continue mes lectures donc là on est toujours en train de lire Schopenhauer on a quasiment fini
et je pense qu'on va passer à un autre bouquin après voilà ça va continuer il va y avoir d'autres choses
les méditations elles continuent pour l'instant.
Elles sont que guider maintenant le mardi et le jeudi
et elles sont en méditation libre le lundi, le mercredi et le vendredi.
Voilà donc encore merci pour votre soutien merci également aux typeurs,
je ne vous remercie pas à chaque vidéo c'est vrai je devrais le faire clairement.
Je sais pas j'en parle rarement sur ma chaîne parce que
c'est pas un truc avec lequel je suis hyper à l'aise vous savez
de vous demander de soutenir le projet mais voilà
si l'envie vous prend de soutenir
le projet de cette chaîne et ce qu'elle devient parce qu'elle est en train de changer un petit peu j'ai l'impression
c'est marrant parce que je dis ça comme si je n'en étais pas le maître
j'en suis pas totalement le maître je crois.
Ça serait intéressant de faire une vidéo d'ailleurs.
Voilà si vous avez envie de soutenir le projet ce sera avec grand plaisir !
et j'ai fait aussi, dernière chose : un discord
c'est un endroit où on peut parler, il y a différents salons de discussion, on peut parler de plein de choses,
on peut échanger sur plein de sujets
voilà le lien est en descriptions
Love, Peace, Ciao !
(sous titre : paul_br)